what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and marvel fans are
getting really really excited because
san diego comic con is this weekend and
marvel studios will be attending hall h
and if you're not familiar with san
diego comic-con and hall h and marvel's
history there this is typically where
they reveal all of their major
announcements and everybody's wondering
well what exactly is going to be
revealed and announced at san diego
comic con this year on saturday and
that's what we're going to be talking
about today we're talking any movie or
show that's going to be getting a
trailer any movie or show that is going
to get officially announced like the
thunderbolts any type of footage that's
going to be shown for a movie or tv show
that won't necessarily be a trailer and
some updates possibly about the
fantastic four x-men and even more and
maybe even get some release dates for
these long anticipated movies and shows
we've been waiting for so let's not
waste any time and jump right into
trailers which trailers for what shows
or movies should we expect to be
released at san diego comic con well of
course the biggest one right now that
everybody's waiting for and expects to
be released at san diego comic con is
black panther 2 wakanda forever
yesterday i did a whole video on what i
expect to see in the teaser trailer when
they finally do show us the trailer the
only question is when exactly are they
going to release it well like i said
hall h is the big show this is where
they drop major things this is where
they revealed in 2019 the entire phase 4
slate so if there was a time to get a
trailer for black panther 2 it would be
during hall h plus not to mention
tragically chadwick boseman passed away
after the last comic con in 2019 and
marvel studios has only briefly talked
about what to expect they did say that
they are not going to recast t'challa
they did not say that they won't choose
a new black panther only that t'challa
won't be recast but marvel hasn't really
said much after that so we can expect
them to address this in some way shape
or form and most likely give us the
actual trailer and of course if they do
indeed release the trailer at san diego
comic-con they most likely will put that
online at the same time as people do
have a tendency to film there even
though you're not supposed to and post
it online so they probably are going to
jump the gun and post it online at the
same time now probably the only other
trailer we're going to get not footage
but specifically a trailer is going to
be for she-hulk it's the next full
marvel project coming out and it's going
to have nine episodes we've only gotten
one trailer for this so far and it comes
out in less than a month now so the full
main trailer is actually overdue so if
they do show another trailer it is
probably for she-hulk now let's talk
footage and just to make it clear
trailers and footage are separate
trailers will most likely be released to
the public at the same time they're
shown at san diego comic-con however
footage will most likely be only for the
people attending hall h disney did this
for star wars celebration when they
showed the andor trailer at star wars
celebration they also released it online
at the same time however they did show
us footage of the mandalorian season 3
and the ahsoka series and that was not
put online because they weren't exactly
official trailers they were just footage
although the mandalorian season 3
footage pretty much looked like a
trailer but the good news about this is
is that people can actually post online
what they saw not post the footage but a
full description of what they just saw
so whatever they show to hall h will
know about and if any footage gets
released here's what i'm expecting to
see the next movie coming out is wakanda
forever but following that is ant-man
and the wasp quantum mania so if there
is any footage that we expect to see i'm
expecting it to be for ant-man 3. with
this hopefully would come the full
official reveal of kang and possibly
even modoc who has been rumored to be
one of the villains of ant-man on the
wasp quantomania for some time now the
next movies coming out after that are
the guardians of the galaxy vol 3 and
the marvels which of course is captain
marvel 2. all of which we should
actually have footage of now there are
two different options for showing
footage of these three movies at sdcc
one is while they talk about all of
these future projects they have the cast
come up on stage and then they show a
little clip of something from the movie
this has been done many times before and
this is what disney did at star wars
celebration whatever movie or show that
they're talking about if they have
footage for that they could show it when
they're giving it it's a lot of time to
talk about they could show it then so
it's not actually limited to these three
movies ant-man 3 guardians 3 and the
marvels pretty much anything that they
have footage done for they could show
but the other option is what marvel
actually likes to do they like to do
these highlight reels where they show a
bunch of different footage for a bunch
of different movies and shows upcoming
and they put it all into one trailer
this is kind of likely but actually
probably more likely a d23 and also keep
in mind if anything is not shown here
there is also a big chance that it could
be saved for disney's d23 event that's
coming in september but then we have
movies and shows that could be
officially announced by kevin feige and
this is kind of the big thing this is
the biggest part of the show typically
marvel studios comes out and reveals the
new projects now in this case they
already went ahead and revealed a ton of
different upcoming projects like armor
wars agatha house of harkness iron heart
echo so they might focus on these a
little bit but what else are they going
to be revealing well the first thing
that i actually hope they reveal is the
nova movie back in march of this year
deadline reported that marvel studios is
developing a nova project deadline is
obviously a trusted outlet so this
should be legitimate but marvel studios
hasn't announced it themselves so
hopefully we get that this saturday the
next project that has been announced by
a trade company but not officially by
marvel studios is the thunderbolts movie
now obviously marvel studios is setting
up the thunderbolts it's very clear that
valentina is recruiting for a team but
we don't have the official announcement
for the film yet so i would love to get
that this weekend the next one is
captain america ford now this kind of
has been confirmed by marvel it's been
confirmed by the writer of the falcon
and the winter soldier he is going to be
directing captain america 4 and he's
confirmed it but still no official
announcement yet so this is definitely
on the table then of course we have and
i know everybody's really excited for
this daredevil it's been reported by a
ton of different outlets and insiders
that daredevil is getting his own series
an official announcement for this with
charlie cox returning to play matt
murdock would be amazing and since they
already put him in spider-man no way
home and everybody's talking about it
it's pretty much done deal we just need
that official announcement and the last
one is werewolf by night which we know
is coming but we have yet to hear
anything official from marvel studios so
this will probably get announced as well
and now for the big stuff the stuff that
everybody's really been waiting for and
that is going to be the updates on
movies that have been announced by kevin
feige and this is going to be deadpool 3
fantastic four and the x-men i would
absolutely love and hope and kind of
expect ryan reynolds to show up at hall
h ryan reynolds has posted pictures of
him at marvel studios and plenty of
people have offered updates about the
script for deadpool 3. i'm not expecting
any type of footage whatsoever because
they have not even started filming but
ryan reynolds making an appearance would
be pretty epic and since he is now
officially a part of the mcu i would
think that he would want to be there as
well now of course the last thing that
kevin feige said at sdcc in 2019 was a
mention of the fantastic four and
mutants now kevin feige would go on to
say that john watts would direct a
fantastic four giving us an update
however john watts has since backed out
deciding to take a break after directing
the spider-man homecoming trilogy but
kevin feige did mention that it is
actively in development so if there's
any type of update for the fantastic
four i'm expecting to hear it maybe even
get a casting announcement if they're
ready for that this is definitely the
time and place to do it especially with
some fans not being too excited about
phase four some fantastic four news
specifically casting news could really
pump up the fans and of course last but
definitely not least the mutants slash
x-men and kevin feige did say the terms
are interchangeable he uses both we have
actually had zero updates about the
mutants in the mcu up until miss marvel
kevin feige teased it at 2019's
comic-con and we heard nothing about it
up until miss marvel's finale where they
revealed that she was indeed a mutant
and played the theme for the x-men 97
animated series and the great thing is
is a few weeks before this kevin feige
actually said that soon we're going to
see how everything is starting to get
connected and where everything is
heading so due to him saying that and
due to miss marvel confirming the
mutants in the mcu i would say that
there is a possibility for some kind of
an update about the x-men and mutants
and again if there is any type of big
reveal this is the place to do it and
the last thing i would expect from sdcc
is just some release dates for some
projects that have already been
announced but as you can see this
weekend has the potential to be super
super exciting and just so everyone's
aware this is my realistic list of what
to expect this weekend but you never
know something could come out of left
field and we could get completely blown
away even more but let me know what you
would love to be revealed at san diego
comic con this saturday drop your
thoughts down below don't forget to like
the video and of course subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
marvel news for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof